[Música]
o que eu mais gostei do detex eu tenho
recusado ultimamente algumas palestras
que não cérebro já cansou um pouco mas
quando estava escrito inconformismo e eu
tenho uma paixão à parte por coimbra
também las em conformismo eu vou eu vou
lá fazer alguma coisa diferente e foi
engraçado eu comecei a pensar na minha
vida quando eu comecei assim conformado
com tudo e eu lembro que eu tinha 17
anos
cheguei na faculdade eu tinha na escola
mas menos 12 valores eu queria fazer
engenharia então não tinha capacidade
intelectual para estudar engenharia e
acabei escolhendo um curso que não
precisa ser inteligente para fazer que a
publicidade comunicação fala já que eu
não consegui la junto com a malta que é
bom eu vou com o pessoal que é mais
descolado e foi engraçado porque logo na
terceira semana que eu estava na
faculdade
o pessoal do último ano falou pra mim
andré onde você está trabalhando
trabalhando em nada tem 17 anos acabei
de chegar da faculdade
a nossa tem que arrumar emprego agora se
não você não vai ser ninguém na vida há
tabu então eu quero ser alguém na vida
que eu preciso de alguém você conhece
alguém em alguma agência de publicidade
não conheço ninguém você tem um
currículo
falei tenho tem um currículo sim desde
então traz amanhã pode dar uma olhada
eu fui pra casa da minha mãe eu falei
que eu tenho um currículo podiam me
ajuda a fazer por favor não é claro
filho
vamos lá pega um currículo na internet a
gente vai preenchendo mp que aqueles
currículo padrão da fala mãe que eu
coloco aqui no nome o seu nome né
fui lá só que tudo interativo état
funciona tudo ao mesmo tempo
andré abané mãe qualquer unidade 17 a
acabou
7o mãe que eu já fiz na vida
não fez nada
o que eu coloco nessa parte do currículo
que assina criativo faz um desenho abu
fazer um desenho que a gente contém 17
anos desenha não sei que a vamos
desenhar
eu falei mãe olha me desenhei afundar
mas só está muito ruim saber que vai ser
alguém isso aí faz uma coisa com a
atitude é uma coisa que mostre que você
é diferente
isso tudo você vai ver que raiva da
você faz quando está nervoso e aí
o pinto é a pílula como é que é
minha mãe falou acho que isso é um pouco
infantil nessa vai mostrar um currículo
com uma pílula
eu não sei o que começou a acontecer na
minha cabeça da frente é impossível não
conheço ninguém no mercado publicitário
e não tenha ocorrido o que eu posso
fazer
eu comecei a pensar em algumas ativações
para conseguir emprego
tá bonito tá isso todos os desenhos foi
o que fiz só tem um título foi o que eu
pensei assim onde eu quero trabalhar
quero trabalhar naquela agência de
publicidade não fui lá descobri quem
quer o diretor de criação da agência de
publicidade comecei a seguir ele ver
onde ele morava que hora que ele levava
os filhos na escola
eu descobri que ele morava perto de casa
estava em 15 da manhã na frente da casa
dele esperando uma surpresa e chegou
estafeta animação que eu fiz em after
effects chegou estafeta porque no brasil
no domingo de manhã os estafetas jogam o
jornal para a casa das pessoas eo
aparelho está feito foi o meu tio morar
aqui na casa da frente
você pode me entregar o jornal que eu
vou fazer uma surpresa para ele
tá eu só com a linha estava lá cinco da
manhã sentadinho eu peguei
tirei o jornal da sacola e tinha feito
uma ativação e específica eu fiz uma
capa falsa pelo jornal aqui do estado de
são paulo tinha feito com várias
notícias linha escrever um pouco do meu
pai e do meu perfil e dentro do caderno
de criatividade de cultura
eu escrevi um papel na mão se eu
conseguir chegar em você
aqui na chegada
maneira eu consigo pensar nos seus
clientes de uma maneira diferente e
fechei o plástico daquela para dentro de
uma empolgada de cara muito do que você
fica todo empolgado quando você faz uma
ação dessas e fiquei esperando ele me
ligar por acaso esse no meu telefone
antigo mas esse é o meu atual se alguém
quiser me ligar um dia tá aí eu fiquei
lá no outro dia na faculdade de repente
toca o telemóvel daí eu falo
andrea banese está falando isso a você é
um filho da você invadiu a
privacidade você não pode fazer isso
você tem que ter cuidado
eu fiquei todo assustado e só vêm aqui
amanhã na agência pra gente conversar eu
fui lá falei mãe por favor vai comigo na
entrevista eu não sei o que ele vai
fazer comigo
fui lá da minha mãe falou é melhor
deixar aqui na porta não vai ser
estranho está sentada do seu lado e meu
filho sei que tá entrevistar eu falei tá
bom fui lá ele olhou pra mim e falou por
que você fez isso
olha eu não tenho currículo não conheço
ninguém não tem um portfolio eu só tenho
essa ideia ruim aí vocês não querem se
você não quiser receber nada de dinheiro
você pode começar a trabalhar na agência
e começou o meu mundo de trabalhar em
agências de publicidade e foi a primeira
vez que eu não conhecia o mais ou menos
né
mas foi a primeira vez que eu pensei
toda vez que eu for fazer algo eu vou
fazer diferente e comecei a trabalhar em
outras agências sempre procurando coisa
diferente vi que todo mundo fazer a
mesma coisa até que chegou um dia eu
falei 'não problema não sou eu
o problema é o brasil o brasil não
presta ninguém pensa em nada diferente
eu vou embora daqui
eu peguei o jogo do risco sabe o jogo de
estratégia começa a descobrir para onde
você vai falar não fala espanhol não
fala inglês não falou nada sobre o que
sobrou portugal olha que o avião que eu
fiz animação animação que eu fiz alta
aí essa aqui é a bandeira de portugal
que o desenho tão bem se alguém não
conseguisse descobrir eu escrevi aqui
cheguei em portugal e foi engraçado que
logo que eu cheguei em portugal
eu tinha 21 anos eu vim com mil euros
pensando que eu poderia ficar um ano
não foi eu não gostava nada na casa dos
meus pais net você não gasta dinheiro
não bebia não fumava se torna na casa
dos pais a comida está lá há cinco mil
anos e ficou um ano fácil
o dinheiro começou a acabar eu comecei a
entrar um pouquinho desespero é preciso
procurar empregos e fazer qualquer coisa
até que eu estava numa festa dessas do
mercado publicitário conheci uma pessoa
e ela falou olha fiquei sabendo que
trabalha com marketing de guerrilha nas
ações diferenciadas
você não quer fazer alguma coisa pelos
canais fox eu tenho um orçamento para
marketing de guerrilha
nossa eu quero que eu tenho que fazer
venho trabalhar na agência com quem você
trabalha ou não se pode criar uma sul
faz o que for
eu criei a toque bonito
a primeira agência de marketing de
guerrilha em portugal e comecei a
trabalhar com os canais fox apresentando
idéias que na verdade uma arte de
guerrilha ele é a agência mais
inconformada que tem que você esquece as
mídias tradicionais não é que a tv
revista jornal e pensa em como fazer
coisas diferentes para gerar boca a boca
na nossa primeira ação que foi pra rua
geração do dexter que eu fiz eu cheguei
os mictórios nos centros comerciais
troquei as pastilhas azuis que
normalmente as meninas não sabemos
quando está viajando lá
depois desse aperto autoclismo saía um
líquido azul
não troquei pelo líquido encarnado e
escrevi se você é viciado em sangue
assistir dexter e coloquei lá só que
como é que funciona o homem né
o homem é muito fácil de você e
comunicar se você dá um amigo em uma
cerveja está todo feliz mas a gente vai
lá a gente vai no mictório a gente
começa a mijar da gente fica fazendo
dezembro e shishin é
daí tem uma mosquinha sinte mira nela
quando tenha naftalina a gente fica
brincando de empurrar a gente é bobo e
na hora que puxar o autoclismo e começa
a sair sangue
mesmo assim futuros
você vai voltar com todos seus amigos e
já junto e fala da pena do outros a
tirar foto e essa ação apareceu em 120
blogs teve um retorno de três milhões de
euros de retorno mediático e eu gastei
40 euros para fazer o que aconteceu
depois a agência começou a crescer dá
ótimos ligou pra gente falou olha a
gente é patrocinador do optimus alive
quero que vocês pensem em uma ação
diferenciada do que a gente fez o que
todo mundo fazia aquelas mesma coisa tá
chaveirinho da short
a gente criou os homens ombros você
chegava lá pegavam dessa emprestado pra
você subir no ombro dele ficava lá era
um homem emprestado pra você ficar em
cima do ombro dele se mostrar a vodafone
ea tmn não pôde utilizar esse serviço
daí depois
esse é um dos mais famosos que
inconformados que a gente já fez também
que a luciana abreu junto com yannick
djaló tiveram uma foi tiveram uma filha
e o nome era lyonce victoria
eu que sou brasileiro falei tá se nome é
normal mas os portugueses estão todos
indignados ou não isso não pode ser
então vamos brincar aqui iam ficar o
nome cada um deles e vamos ficar então
seria lá escrevi aqui tipo andré abané
oitava que tudo lhe iam ficar aparece o
seu nome
a gente colocava o once seu nome milhão
ficado é um dom henrique na já apertava
no facebook com partilhava isso duas
milhões de pessoas
leões ficaram nome em portugal uma merda
de idéia que a gente fez no fim do dia
depois o cliente do alguém deve ser
devem conhecer a série está passando
agora também eles tinham tinha chegado
dos estados unidos 1 milhão de produtos
do ranking de chances porta-chaves copo
isso tudo a gente criou uma loja no
dolce vita tejo que pra você comprar os
produtos do ranking desde em vez de
dinheiro você tinha que dar sangue
como assim dar sangue é em vez de gastar
20 anos essa chance eu tinha aqui doar
400 ml no caso que o máximo você pode
doar e tinha um jogo do playstation que
era 10 mil ml eo puto levou a família
inteira dele todo mundo mal humorado é
uma fila gigante mas não interessa
conseguiu muito mais de doação de sangue
é aqui que eu tenho nem tem uma coisa
também que eu trouxe que é surreal eu
não sei quando quem trabalha em
comunicação e marketing deve ter uma
cadeira na na faculdade em portugal
pra você fazer alguma coisa pra gerar
boca a boca tem que fazer a maior coisa
do mundo tem que bater o recorde do
guinness é o maior croácia seja feita em
coimbra maior pastel de nata não sei da
onde maior feijoada no vasco da gama eo
rock in rio decidiu fazer a maior árvore
de natal da europa
eu até fiz em dois aqui de tão grande
que ela olha o tamanho dela quer
e foi lá na praça do comércio todo mundo
falou um monte de televisão não sei o
quê
e daí no outro ano a câmara de lisboa
não tinha mais dinheiro para patrocinar
porque era caro e no dia do lançamento
um ano depois decidi fazer o lançamento
da menor área da europa
ela era 257 vezes menor que o ano
passado e tinha 110 mil vezes - lâmpada
ea gente teve um retorno de mídia de 300
mil euros
apareceu em capas de jornal tipo menor
árvore de natal da europa é lançada na
praça do comércio
vocês podem ver os vídeos natal da
internet que existe por aí
mas o que eu aprendi na eu coloco aqui
que eu aprendi com isso muita gente
nesse percurso eu já tô aqui em portugal
há 15 anos sempre vêm falar o que eu
tenho que fazer
acho que desde a nossa educação mais ou
menos é assim que por esse caminho
você tem que por aquilo e eu sempre
paguei pra isso os fundos vão fazer do
meu jeito não quer saber de você faz ou
inventados business law inventava as
coisas na empresa exame ferrava porque
não pagava imposto que eu achava que não
devia pagar só que daí eu vi que tinha
alguma
regras só que eu aprendi que a gente só
consegue ser feliz e muito legal a toque
de maio fornece a gente faz o nosso
caminho
a gente vai ficar seguindo que um dirceu
seguiu que steve jobs fez ou que usou o
verbo fez acho que isso não vai dar em
nada
só que o que foi legal disso eu estava
com isso dentro de mim
depois de dez anos com a agência eu
tinha um monte de dinheiro no banco
falei caramba o cheio de dinheiro e eu
não gostava nada comia lasanha congelada
no almoço e pisa congelado do minipreço
à noite e trabalhava e que eu fiz eu
tinha 300 mil euros na conta eu comecei
a ligar para meus amigos e falar assim ó
não quer sair dessa sua empresa chata
que reclama toda vez que eu saí como eu
vou pagar se não te pago quanto é que
ganha por ano 20 mil euros tido 20 mil
euros
você venha me da sociedade na sua ideia
de 50%
ontem 11 empresas assim e tinha 15
sócios
imagina como virou minha vida vida que
era para ser bonita legal criativo eu
virei o rei do excel ficava falando com
o advogado contabilidade virou inferno
até que um dia e minha mulher fez esse
desenho ontem no hotel que ela falou
caminha bomba estava feia superbonita
essa bomba
estourei deu bernal tineke que chama
comecei a ficar louco porque eu vivia
entre são paulo e lisboa e istambul
catar onde eu tinha as empresas a tomar
banho em avião não sabe onde tinha
deixado aquela cueca
meu cérebro estava totalmente perdido
até que eu falei pra todos os meus
sócios falei olha não quero mais saber
de portugal não quero mais saber dessas
agência tudo vai todo mundo
desculpa por dizer que eu vou
embora e decidir por japão
no japão o mais legal disso tudo o que
eu pensei
ninguém me conhece lá nunca ninguém me
viu eu posso fazer o que eu quiser
joguei tudo nas coisas da forma que eu
tinha e fiz seis chances
amanda tweetar de friday weekend
fiquei com duas calças de ganga 67 antes
cético épocas e fui pra ficar seis meses
é muito bom isso esvazia a sua cabeça e
que tinha hoje
quarta é neste chegava terça e quinta
era bem lixados que seja tem sete anos
de hotéis de luxo em gastar um pouco
mais e disser e a pior idéia que eu tive
até hoje foi fazer uma chance para o fim
de semana
o suvaco amarelo e duas semanas
daí que eu fui fazer no japão fui pensar
um pouco na vida pensei refletir e foi
engraçado que eu voltei para portugal
comecei a dar palestra de criatividade
até que um ponto em aveiro depois das
perguntas e falou andré já fez tanta
coisa famosos que se não tem uma coach
rui coutinho odeia o culto nunca
acreditei nessa merda de coaching
mas você tem que fazer uma nova lei está
bom eu comecei a pesquisar sobre gols
desculpa eu sei que o texas um monte de
couro enquanto um monte de coisas mas eu
comecei a ver que as contas era tudo
contraditória
isso nunca é tarde para aprender governo
aprende línguas
cada qual com seu igual eu só posso
atrás não poupar é que está o ganho é
preciso gastar dinheiro a fazer dinheiro
faz falta o que eu vou seguir qual conta
eva asa e daí chegando mesmo no fim eu
falei quer saber vou fazer minha coach
vou mostrar pra todo mundo e é com essa
aqui que eu vou fazer sucesso
obrigado marco
[Aplausos]